we have now had in this country more
controversy over dave chappelle making
jokes about transness than we had over
joe biden completely surrendering an
entire country to the taliban which
shows you where our priorities are as a
nation
but dave chappelle for his part is doing
something quite important he's standing
up and he's just saying no and that's
really really important it's important
because most of the people who are
targeted by the woke cancel culture
crowd are not dave chappelle they're not
one of the most powerful comedians on
the planet who's worth a bajillion
dollars most people are people who are
targeted inside their organizations
people who are outed for some comment on
facebook people who have been ostracized
from their social circles and when they
see dave chappelle saying no they too
are empowered to say no because that's
the thing about the counselors you don't
have to be canceled if you don't want to
be canceled now that doesn't mean they
won't be fired it doesn't mean they
won't feel repercussions it does mean
there's a whole side of the aisle out
here waiting to embrace you if you
decide that you don't care whether you
are canceled or not by people who
despise you anyway so dave chappelle did
another comedy bit yesterday
and
in this comedy bit he explicitly talked
about meeting with the trans community
right this is something that many of the
people who were protesting him demanded
a meeting a meeting they needed a
meeting now i'm not sure what they think
would get done at the meeting other than
they would get to lecture chappelle and
they think what chappelle was going to
just sit there and apologize for his
jokes which comedians typically are not
in the vein of doing well chappelle did
another comedy set last night and he
addressed exactly this complaint and
demand
to the transgender community i'm more
than willing
to give you an audience
but she will not summon me
i am not bending to anybody's demands
and if you want to meet with me i'd be
more than willing to
but i have some conditions
first of all
you cannot come
if you have not watched my special from
beginning to end you must come to a
place of my choosing
and a time
of my choosing
and thirdly
you must admit
that hannah gatsby is not funny
[Laughter]
i'm sorry like i'm sorry that he's funny
guys i'm sorry that he's funny and then
he's going to continue to be very
successful because he is funny now even
chappelle who is again the most
successful comedian on planet earth that
netflix plays and pays him just
oodles of cash in order to get him to do
his specials with them even chappelle is
now saying that he is at risk of being
de-platformed he says he produces
documentary and many of the major
distributors will no longer touch his
work other than his comedy specials
they're happy to make money off his
comedy specials but they're not going to
look at his ancillary work because he's
just too offensive here he was
discussing this
this film that i made was invited to
every film festival in the united states
and some of those invitations i accepted
and when this controversy
came out
about the close-up
they began disinviting me from these
film festivals and now
today
not a film company not a movie studio
not a film festival nobody will touch
this film thank god for teds randalls
and netflix he's the only one that
didn't cancel me yet
okay so he's uh thanking god for netflix
we'll see how long netflix lasts or
whether they choose to undergo this
controversy again and here's the thing
dave chappelle i'm sure that you and i
disagree on nearly everything i'm sure
that you have attacked people who work
with daily wire i mean i know you have
you've done it publicly with for example
candace owens i don't care i'd be happy
to work with dave chappelle i'm sure
candace owns would be happy to have dave
chappelle working over here too we don't
care because we are much more
open-minded than the left is when it
comes to jokes that target us again in
dave chappelle special he tells two
separate anti-semitic jokes no one seems
to care including me because the fact is
that while i don't like the jokes and i
don't really think they're funny
i am not the arbiter of what great humor
is i'm not the sole arbiter nor do i
feel that people ought to be silenced on
the basis of me not liking a particular
joke
so if he's looking for distributors who
are never going to cancel him he will
find himself on the right side of the
aisle sooner or later whether he likes
it or not because the left is just going
to continue
cordoning off all the areas where dave
chappelle is allowed to work there is a
great irony by the way in the fact that
the vast majority of people who are very
angry at dave chappelle are upper-class
white liberals
you have a black man who's becoming
incredibly successful by telling jokes
coming from a background that was not
wealthy
and you have a bunch of upper-class
white woke liberals who are very very
upset at dave chappelle because he
noticed that a man is a woman that a man
is a woman is a nonsensical statement
because he noticed that men are men and
women are women and human beings are
sexually dimorphous
like because you noticed that the white
wolf liberals are very mad any other
situation where you had a bunch of upper
class white folks attacking a black
person it would be totally unheard of
it'd be really wrong right and just
another element of the intersectional
hierarchy of privilege rearing its ugly
head
but when it's dave chappelle telling
jokes about a uh community that is
supposedly at the top of the
intersectional hierarchy of victimology
then dave chappelle must be brought to
heal so good for him for saying no
on all of that
as he pointed out he said i've been it's
been said in the press i was invited to
speak to the transgender employees of
netflix and i refused that's not true if
they'd invited me i would have accepted
it although i'm confused about what we
would be speaking about i said what i
said and boy i heard what you said my
god how could i not you said you want a
safe working environment in netflix it
seems like i'm the only one that can't
go to the office anymore
and then he continued he said this
really isn't about the lgbt community
he says this has nothing to do with them
it's about corporate interests and what
i can say and what i cannot say
for the record i need you to know this
everyone i know from that community has
been loving and supporting so i don't
know what all this nonsense is about
okay that i'm sure that is right by the
way i'm sure the vast majority of lgbtq
people who watch the chappelle special
are like
or they laughed or they don't care but
the activist class are the class that
run our media and run the corporate
board rooms so chappelle happens to be
right about that so it's very important
what chappelle is doing right now now is
it enough to
actually create a groundswell of
ignoring these folks
i doubt it
i mean he praises ted sarandos over at
netflix serendo's already offered a
quasi apology for aaron chappelle
special he said well yeah we should have
aired chappelle special but i should
have told the offended employees that i
understood their feelings and all that
that is always the prelude to the
alligator taking off an arm
netflix already fed them a finger
now it's just a matter of how far they
allow the alligator to go
whereas chappelle is cutting it off at
the beginning so good for him because we
need more of this in our society more jk
rowlings more dave chappelles again i
disagree i'm sure with jk rowling and
dave chappelle on nearly everything
but as i've said before the future of
this country and indeed of civilization
and freedom rest not with people on the
right who've already made our call that
we are in favor of individual freedom
nor does it lie with the radical left
which has made their call that they
don't care about individual freedom so
long as they are pursuing quote unquote
redistributive justice
it lies in the middle with people who
may have sympathy for the agenda items
of the radical left but who believe that
individual rights take precedence and
that if forced to choose between
individual right and preservation of
their durability
and the agenda items of the left they
will choose individual rights and the
preservation of their durability even if
it takes longer to get to their policy
preference
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video